con la aprobación del parlamento
británico tanto en la cámara de los
comunes como la de los lores y la
sanción de la reina isabel como jefa de
estado de esta ley de la relación futura
entre el reino unido y la unión europea
este primero de enero en las primeras
horas del 2021 empezará a regir esa
nueva relación entre londres y bruselas
que se prevé un poco menos tormentosa
recordemos han sido 50 años de esa
relación entre aliados estratégicos
entonces gran parte de esta nueva
relación será un acuerdo de libre
comercio que no tiene ni cuotas ni
tarifas dice el primer ministro que
además le permite el reino unido-
recuperar su autonomía en leyes
soberanía en aguas en fronteras en
recursos y que además será la
oportunidad para que el reino unido-
busque acuerdos de libre comercio con
otros países como eeuu que es una de sus
prioridades han sido 50 años de
altibajos en esta relación un divorcio
caótico
banco en el 2016 con el referendo para
salir de la unión europea y le ha
costado a este país dos primeros
ministros david cameron y theresa may
luego vino boris johnson quien concretó
el break sin el reino unido- dejó
definitivamente la unión europea el 31
de enero de este año luego vino la
negociación tortuosa también de este
acuerdo comercial y la futura
negociación que concluirá en las
próximas en las próximas horas entonces
este 31 de diciembre concluye el periodo
de transición y también esta relación
compleja